[Musique]
bonjour alors mais vrai qu'est-ce qui
nous a ramené vieux bus y ait six vous
mais plein de trucs
bah ça va beaucoup mieux sans moi ça va
et bing va pas voler ça lui a fait écho
à des marques comme ça en décrochant
j'ai fait un nouveau truc j'ai refait le
piège des tartes
j'ai réussi 14 étapes et jouer avec les
équipes d'âge deux ont voulu me le faire
mais je sais en fait on a fait croire
qu'on refusait les badges pour la
rentrée était que tu m'aies tête-à-tête
pour refaire le match et tout raconté
tôt dès que j'arrivais le matin petit
bureau non j'ai fais tes de mayol nous
sommes encore avoir de la tarte à la
crème allez merci mais je voulais mais
y'en a qui n'ont pas vu mais oui on a
réussi à piéger pas mal de moi c'est
très drôle et surtout un des gars de
sécu ouais à quel point on en sait qu
d'aller voir la sécu d'âge 2 oh non ça
va annoncer là c'est du lourd je peux
vous dire attendez pas petite aiguille
et sur le set à la grande et sur le 49
c'est pas l'heure de même quatre heures
télé mais je suis fan est pas là je vais
pas partir je sais toujours pourvus ce
qu'il fallait pas rater à la télé ces
dernières 24 heures mais très très vite
d'aller voir son influence appartient
plus c'est parti j'ai regardé c'est au
programme un pour une fois la chronique
de la colline de sophie alexandre a
beaucoup intéressé la sauce aux ailes en
forme des matins essayer de comprendre
les records à celui là c'est adele dans
le michigan
gravel premier qu'est ce qu'il a l'avion
que voilà 44 cm
salut royal et on accroît on a trouvé
l'enfant de stars de thierry lhermitte
et du personnage d'eli semoun regarder
il trouve enfin le corbeau
le voici
[Musique]
les aventuriers
regardez ya nicolas qui a utilisé le mot
binôme pour être honnête trio rennais
marché ce rosé rouge moi ça serait
parfait pour moi mes deux potes binôme à
trois ans jusqu'en finale c'est un
triomphe l'hérault tiens d'ailleurs si
les uns cherchent des petits nouveaux on
a le cast parfait dans personne n'y
avait pensé que celle de savoir qui va
jouer en quelle position ensuite dans la
manche suivante frédéric avoue un verbe
qui se termine par rires fous rires tu
fous rires je fous rires de faurisson et
patrick bosso regarder se rappeler de
vieux souvenirs et regarder qui a joué
vraiment besoin de ces films à ses
débuts on croirais s'il est déjà la
castagne je m'attelle à thé l'étranger
tu me tues mais attendez là dessus sur
et est l'étrangère fois qu'il attendait
pas là dessus je t'attends personne
personne dans les pas du tout d'abord la
version australienne de nikos dans the
voice
il ya aussi douce et sans tous les pays
notamment en australie regarder
rapidement visiblement n'avait pas fait
les repérages plateau regardez sinon il
ya cela pointe son nez ça se passe bien
ça se passe mal et des enfants depuis
tout va bien au québec regarder ya une
animatrice qui vois une araignée sur sa
table en plein dans son jt et en grande
professionnelle elle garde son calme
enfin quasiment quoi pour un montant de
4 milliards et demi dans la premier midi
qui c'est un projet vital pour l'inter
qui voit ses protégés
guy est un point peut pas cru libre ou
en alberta et en colombie britannique
quatre autres victimes devaient
retranché mais ça fait le tour des jt à
nice christian estrosi a inauguré une
chose que les niçois attendait depuis
très longtemps franchement c'est beau
[Musique]
bravo bravo pour cette magnifique
en ce moment il ya roland ses rôles en
tout neuf à roulement fer un dess voire
une demie chantaco dans les tribunes de
l'anglais et moi je matte à la télé ya
lionel chamoulaud côtés de arnaud
clément vous savez il commente avec
arnaud clément
le chéri de nolwenn leroy on le vide
arrête pas de le dire le dis tout le
temps et ce qui est bien c'est que quand
il faut un peu de promo pour nolwenn
match ça se voit à peine m le service
public on le fait en discret
nolwenn est toujours au tournant car il
était là ce matin mais encore des dates
et bien sûr tous cas la fin de l'année
les festivals pendant cet été libre 5 3
c'est dans lion d'alice et de faire un
petit paul maintenant il sait que ça
peut fonctionner mais vu ses scoops il
part pas de roland pour devenir le
rédacteur en chef de sa maman la soeur
et mon fiancé 2 de rafael nadal
la dation de raphaël quitté au tac
copine finalement copine de france
angels et de sa copine d'école de la
soeur voilà tout est sens pas comme cela
bienvenue sur sa peau foncée aussi
l'embauché les plus grands météorologues
c'est important au monde pour prévoir le
temps qu'il fera avec une précision
immense bien sûr bonjour à tous plus
important mesdames messieurs c'est qu'il
ne va pas pleuvoir cet après midi ça
c'est vraiment l'essentiel on est
soulagé on a eu droit à une belle après
de tennis un pleut il pleut comme peut
le constater ça y est les gens quittent
le coup arrive le voir cet après-midi
pompe et la polémique cette année vous
l'avez peut-être vu c'est que rafael
nadal un peu moins à la caisse que les
autres années et y en a qui lui dit ce
qui prend plus de temps pour servir pour
récupérer un petit peu alors on a
regardé je trouve ces des polémiques
abuser c'est pas si loin que ça
[Musique]
l'euro perd 3,2 ballon quand j'ai
regardé maison à vendre aussi sur m6
karine a vendu la maison de gérard
stéphane plaza mais franchement il est
cool il a bien vendu
j'ai en tout cas j'espère pour lui parce
que vu les vannes qui se prend dans la
gueule tout au long de l'émission
pour arriver à vendre sa maison et s'en
prend plein la gueule c'est d'être
vendeur regardez 330 1902 dans votre
poche
ouais donc que si moche ces petits
chaussons
nous accompagnons j'ai partagé à cuba
gégé a tellement pris plein la gueule
que le moindre geste de stéphane ça les
nerfs gérard à la fin ne supporte plus
ces magnifiques m'a défoncé la porte
aujourd'hui pendant que vous tourniez le
clip de votre tube cyril on a décidé de
mettre la chanson à fond dans la somme
sauf dans l'ascenseur de h2o beaucoup
trop fort en goût du non-stop pendant
cinq heures impossible de l'arrêter en
début de journée regarder pour titre
c'est sur ce ratage de mais comme
n'importe quel morceau plus les heures
passent plus les visages se sert moi je
vois que lors les gens rient beaucoup
l'or continue de tourner au bout d'un
moment tout le monde et pour l'espagne
au limoges pas chez nous qu'on est comme
la musique était à fond non-stop
tout le monde se renvoie la somme soit
parce que même quand il a l'art et les
gens entend de la musique
vous allez voir tout le monde fasse la
matinée à se renvoyer la faire seule
[Applaudissements]
on a bossé ce match
on a vu notre ami nourdine qui était au
bout du rouleau à 13h quand même on l'a
laissé pendant sept heures en la faisant
bloc beau jeu dont j'ai gardé ça dérange
pas je t'ai pas au bureau pour moi les
gars comme ça fait gaffe quand même des
carburants short kaki beaucoup de lui ça
se fait j'ai regardé le mc de la santé
voilà il recevait une écrivaine qui a
choisi un titre un peu chelou pour son
bouquin ça m'a surpris puis aussi
angoissé ça m'a rappelé un truc ellison
bonjour bonjour publié à la convenance
un tonique mon petit guide décontractée
de la foufoune journaliste café son jt
tranquille mais elle reçoit un appel en
direct qui ne s'arrête jamais à ces
informations ideology and see
jusqu'au bout je puis ça fait des
semaines regarder cette famille à élever
ce papillon c'est tellement mignon ça y
est le jour est venu dé soigner il est
temps de le relâcher en pleine nature
quand la nature et l'émotion de son
client
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a le grand jeu des tartes on a
fait quelques fois j'étais obligé de le
faire quand même une une dernière fois
on a prétendu aux gens de la société de
compte je vais faire des nouveaux badges
et qu'il fallait nous reconnaissance
faciale pour imprimer ce nouveau badge
regardez le dispositif c'est un des plus
réussis qu'on ait fait un à huy les bons
écrans un objectif un clavier et sous le
clavier
bien sûr vous allez le voir la tarte à
partir de là tout s'enchaîne très vite
l'enfant
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
cette année c'est que gecina rendez vous
est aussi sécurisé et criant comme à
l'aller on va le revoir
regardez ils squattent d'abord la tarte
est parti de plus d'une heure mon frère
dit la rose et là il fait quand même un
oscar à stu manque pas de sel défense
mais youssef qu'un comédiens formidables
ouais c'est vrai c'est vraiment grenat
je vais le revoir une dernière fois
regardez
si tout le cabinet
[Applaudissements]